I struggled with friendships due to
political reasons at UCLA why because
people knew that I was originally from
Tennessee and that was something that I
didn't think was contentious but
apparently it was I remember my friends
being super drunk at a party and I
walked in and one of them said there's
our racist friend Brett from Tennessee
and we hadn't even talked about politics
yet my dad's side of the family is all
for North Carolina old like dirt poor
farmers and when I said like farmers in
North Carolina they were like oh so your
family owned slaves and I was like how
did we get there we didn't and then
covet happened and I remember Friends
making me ride in a car by myself like
six months in because it's like well you
know you're on the right so obviously
you don't care about covets you can't
hang out with us because you're probably
like not taking things seriously